alertés sur le web à présent avec ce
problème des suicides dans la police 44
policiers se suicident chaque année en
moyenne un phénomène est un problème qui
est en hausse alors qu'un nouveau
protocole est mise en place place
beauvau
les équipes du web verte et france se
sont entretenus avec l'association à qui
a rencontré marlène schiappa et pour en
parler nous sommes justement avec notre
journaliste web
antoine boitel crt sur le web tout de
suite
[Musique]
bonjour antoine vous avez longuement
enquêté sur ce problème des suicides
dans la police comment est-ce que
évoluent problèmes notamment
alors effectivement comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure il ya une nouvelle étude
de la mutuelle générale de la santé des
forces de sécurité qui vient de sortir
cette semaine qui était révélée par
france info
notamment les venues rappeler avec un
chiffre choc que il ya une stabilité
inexorable en fait du phénomène de
suicides dans la police nationale en
particulier avec 45 morts par an par an
en moyenne
donc c'est depuis 25 ans et 1100 à 1200
policiers c'est à dire l'équivalent
d'une promotion de police entière qui
c'est qui s'est suicidé donc c'est 50 %
de plus qu'en population générale
c'était déjà un chiffre de choc
légalement et on peut en conclure
malheureusement que ya une très forte
stabilité du chiffre qu'on n'arrive pas
à faire baisser cette année le compteur
de la honte comme on l'appelle dans les
associations
il est déjà 16 16 morts depuis depuis
1er janvier est ce que des solutions on
peut être envisagée à ce stade pour y
remédier alors oui justement c'était
l'objet de notre article
il ya un bon bout de la sécurité qui a
été casey un peu en urgence qui n'était
pas du tout prévu au programme
ça s'est passé le 31 mai il ya une table
ronde à huis clos à beauvau qui était
pas diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux en
présence de marines qui à part elle a
demandé à s'en occuper directement si
vous voulez parce qu'elle a rencontré
des familles de l'île de victimes en
cent des familles de des enfants de
policiers notamment dans les dents les
parents s'étaient suicidées et à la
remplacer gérald darmanin sur ce sujet
là parce qu'elle était un peu l'été at
elle dit en tout cas elle était plus
elle été touchée par le phénomène et 7
cette table ronde va t'elle déboucher
selon vous sur sur du concret ou est ce
que c'est un énième plan sans résultat
probant
oui selon christophe girard qui est donc
vice président
l'association peps sos policiers en
détresse que nous avons interrogés lui
il a donc participé ce beau monde de la
sécurité sur les sur les suicides en
paix ce national avec magna pas ils ont
signé entre son association au ministère
un protocole de travail a été signé qui
vise à faire baisser sérieusement le
fléau le fléau en france et c'est une
méthode qui souhaitent importer depuis
montréal ou québec était aussi
expérimenté au royaume uni depuis 2012
et on a déjà observé à l'étranger qu'on
pouvait faire baisser de 70 %
les chiffres de suicide en fait grâce à
cette méthode là et le principe si vous
voulez c'est de s'appuyer sur des
policiers à la fée rang dans l'est dans
les commissariats qui permettent de ne
pas passer directement par un
psychologue pour les politiques veulent
parler à leurs collègues donc les
associatifs on sent que pour une fois
que c'est un sujet que j'ai quand même
souvent traités dont consentez il ya
beaucoup d espoir pour une fois ils ont
un espoir parce qu'ils ont l'impression
que l'administration les écoute enfin et
veut utiliser les méthodes qu'ils ont
mis en place parce qu'il en avait pas il
n'avait pas joué pour eux jusqu'à
présent une petite lueur d'espoir merci
beaucoup antoine malheureusement on n'a
plus le temps de poursuivre ce dossier
passionnant en tout cas on peut le
retrouver évidemment sur rt france
pointé vais donc enquête complète
d'antoine boitel sur les suicides dans
la police